bye
you
it's a big problem and it has to do with
the law of intellectual property and I
guess the perception that I have is that
the rich countries are scientifically
advanced they invest in technology and
they control most of the intellectual
property and patents for things and I
think the cry from Indonesia which is
burst forth more quietly from other
places is that they want some share in
any rights and royalties for discoveries
made with materials diseases or viruses
discovered in their countries that's a
radical change from the passivity of
saying it's the rich countries
responsibility to take care of the poor
countries but it's now putting
tremendous and I think appropriate
demands for just what you said is how do
we share intellectual property how do we
make expensive vaccines available at low
cost as we are for AIDS drugs to people
in Africa
you